here's what would happen if Russia
launched a nuclear weapon
after the launch the United States
military's infrared system would detect
the missile through infrared radiation
in minutes President Joe Biden would be
alerted and the response would likely be
an immediate massive counter-attack
now even a Russian nuke that was only
two-thirds as powerful as the bomb
dropped on Hiroshima would destroy
everything within one kilometer 45
000 people would be killed and another
300 000 injured if Russia and the United
States detonated all their nukes Earth
would become enveloped in a blanket of
soot in just two weeks this would block
sunlight and lower the temperature to
below freezing it could take 10 years
for it to dissipate Russia has signaled
that if any NATO member directly
intervened in the war in Ukraine it
could spell global disaster so